halloween is full of tricks but boy do i
have a treat
for you today do you remember this study
that we talked about on our show a few
weeks ago
okay colorado state university found
that women are less likely
to swipe right or say yes to men
if they're posing with a cat in their
dating profile
ladies nice
other things much more important also
who doesn't love a cat
okay what if these guys were dressed up
in a
costume i mean who can say no to that
okay so i asked a few single men and
their adorable
furry sidekicks to join us today in a
very special halloween costume ready
parade yeah
and i asked our guests and bachelorette
to help me co-host and from comedy
central's
the daily show with trevor noah one of
my favorites still say sloane is here
hello friend okay
you're single and candid about working
on your dating profile during
quarantine yes can you swipe
right with a man with a cat yes
because my i have two cats they live in
my mom's house because they're country
georgia cats
um and i live in new york so they would
not be happy here but
i don't see anything wrong with the man
is he alive
i mean is he breathing i'd rather swipe
right on a dude with a cat
than some dude who wants to go hiking
and bungee jumping and skydiving you
want to die
don't bring me with you are you ready
for our halloween
yes i want to see these kitties cats i
want to see these manzis
okay first up is bachelor number one tim
and his pal hank where is it
[Applause]
softly do you have a question for tim
and hank if i met you
like out about in public uh what would
you do to get me to notice you
uh i mean i'd probably start by wearing
this outfit and then
uh fleet week as i've heard and carrying
this cat and then i'd walk up to you and
give you my cheesiest pickup line
uh example please uh be mine it's meow
or never
wow
very cheesy right um pure brie
pure chatter he's like well thank you
um tim and hank thank you guys so much
okay next up it's bachelor number two
it's andrew and his sidekick very
okay okay
[Laughter]
do you have a question for andrew and
barry
so what does a perfect date night with
you look like let's see what you did
there
thank you so much um well i'm a big
cyclist so i would say
a nice fun cycle through brooklyn see
some sights
get some tacos home cuddled up with
barry
a bottle of wine and you know watching
our favorite show
i'm afraid to be on a bike in the street
so you'd have to take me to like a park
or something
andrew would you ever like forego the
cycling
and just get to the tacos and the vino
of course
because that sounds fun
well thank you andrew and barry they
that was awesome and very exciting to
meet you and you both are just so lovely
black man black hat
[Applause]
but last and certainly not least is rob
and his
wing man bad news sweet pea uh-oh
wow i have
never met a cat with four names before
what is the most romantic thing that you
have ever done for a lady
well it started uh with me picking her
up at our house with
uh roses and chocolate and we proceeded
to go to a private beach
and i decided sunset wine
dinner on the beach little romantic i'm
a very old school romantic kind of guy
and i proceeded to sing to her an elvis
song and
and it went very well that was the best
date i had
so it's like perfect
where are you from i'm from queens new
york
well that's what that sounds like well
thank you rob and bad news sweet pea
okay so which bachelor would you like to
possibly go on a date with
[Music]
well shouldn't they have to agree to
like it just can't be like you
me date also but that is how i want to
date you me
andrew
i am not gonna lie when andrew walked
out
i felt a spark and i i i'm
very excited for your guys's date um
so this is so fun i hope that you'll
report back
and we're doing a follow-up segment
because this is actually going to happen
this is not just television i did not
put these shoes on to be kind
and ladies who are watching swipe right
next time for a cutie with a cat
thank you dolce and also you can check
her out in the movie
chick fight coming out november 13th
[Music]